nel caso vi steste chiedendo perché fa
vige indossi sempre la stessa maglia da
due settimane no in realtà non è che non
mi lavo anche un po quello però ho
registrato questi video quasi tutti di
fila così sono andato un pochettino in
vacanza anch'io quindi se vesto sempre
questa maglia puzzo sì però meno di
quanto pensate bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti mi sono beni che sono fuori
già oggi siamo sud mamme che the man and
queen warning più 16 ecco io e che 16
non li ho mai capiti come giochi o sono
più 12 quindi da poi qui prima se un po
più bambino 6 p 18 perché dai 16 ai 18
che casse cambia ma scusa cioè il
sinistro gioco i manichini si muovono ai
16 anni non è case dieci anni non lo
capisce a 18 si è manichino is best
player with iphone che tenga da anni
sempre questo è in with 6 michel pure
please put damon now sipro stai calmo
mai fatto bene penso fosse un gioco
schifoso vi riassumo quello che sto
leggendo in questa casa non c'è stato
nessuno per un sacco di tempo per anni
nel 58 l'ultima volta che così non è
stata legge di sotto anche perché non
capite un grazie ma manco io capisco non
solo un po inventato cosa devo trovare
qua vista casa dove trova qualcosa
immagino c'erano le fotocamere che ai
tempi facevano un po schifo e lo capisco
però nessun servizio che gli ha
attaccato il telefono perfetto va bene
non so che cosa dobbiamo trovare in
questa casa ma lo troveremo sicuro io
c'è una cantina
c'è una cantina bene questa cosa la
meglio non scoprirla però non li so
proprio che tanto icona ci posso andare
permesso sono lisa c'è così mi hanno
chiamata al telefono open
ok non sono stato io comunque c'era
cascato non solo ha permesso pur cavalca
è la domanda che stavo per fare ma ci
sono delle luci questa casa che poi è
tipo questa a perfetto
ottimo è buono a scoprirsi sta cosa
adesso che cosa ne ha messi a fare
interruttori se non fu cosa li metti la
domanda è avere fuori si vede
sta piovendo anche simpatico va beh
almeno non siamo nel mezzo del nulla
la domanda è una come faccio io dark
room chi piscia stanza buia tieni chiuso
male perché guarda il resto della casa
era talmente illuminato che mi sta
cecando credimi non cadere per favore
grazie a questo non si apre proprio che
sia aperta si è la domanda che sto per
fare ma questa scusa perché io illumino
davanti a me senza una torcia
io sono gesù ati piani no scusatemi ma
quanti piani shasta casa e quarto che
c'è quattro piani quattro piani di casa
ma stiamo scherzando o salve aki credo
che stai così miglia quattro piani poi
io starei messo peggio
senti la vediamo di stare ma intanto
l'albero entra dentro ma non è un albero
su un foglio ti stai scusando per averlo
lasciato abbandonato per così tanto
tempo anche se non sei stata tu a
lasciarlo
chi lo sporco di sangue tra l'altro a lo
monto io sì facciamo che io mi monto il
mio nemico era un manichino bambino tra
l'altro va bene
prendi prendi prendi braccino ho visto
ho montato lasciamoli io comunque non ho
capito cosa dovrei fare in questa casa
trovare cosa gli sviluppi gli occhi
monta i tool spari sti ok casa la musica
che viene da piano di sotto si aperta
porto va bene che si teletrasporta nost
i mali che sono goku o grazie che mi hai
aperto la porta gentile amici adesso si
è illuminata la casa come poche se è
mosso il manichino la casa e meno horror
di prima ma com'è possibile permesso
esaminarli e fatto benissimo sotto e
bellissimo giuro
tre le foto le foto fanno cagare però
per il resto è veramente figo è fatto
benissimo anche sul sesso o tragedia sul
terrazzo a londra cosa una famiglia è
stata assassinata in questa casa e non
hanno mai ritrovato la bambina ah ecco
se l'avessi trovata io la bambina l'ho
pure montata qui a pezzi come i mobili
dell'ikea senza la guida è un fenomeno
persona perché cesto rumore horror
bruttissima ma allo stesso tempo c'è
musica non si chieda sala d'aspetto va
bene grazie che mi chiudi le porte
questa è sempre chiusa effetti sonori
horror con la musichetta di sottofondo
ma
io lì non c entro per cortesia fatemi
fare altro devo per forza entrarci è
permesso devo imitare la voce di lisa
che così ma non c'era prima
come è comparso dal nulla salve
c'è anche i capelli ma che bello se non
si fosse suicidati panabaker vabbè
andiamo avanti
pensavo che nello nello specchio ci
fosse il riflesso del manichino ma non
c'è il riflesso proprio quindi va bene
facciamo qua lisa se scomponiamo la
parola è sali quindi salire di nuovo no
questa roba qua la catena del cesso ma
non c'è il cesso ok dovrebbe essere la
luce perché mettere un interruttore ti
pesava il culo insomma va beh io uscire
di qua fa piacere fare conoscenze nuove
in ogni stanza in cui rientro molto
bello si sono spostate le scatole
perfetto cosa darà in cantina quanto
sono contento di questa cosa proprio
viso o si è caduto ti sei rotto mi
dispiace e salta non ti molto più io se
rotta anche la maniglia altre porte
no no no mica riesci a sali entrare mica
c'hai la chiave non bastava dire no ero
a posto non devi urlare stai zitta c'è
calma di tutti i cani dove testare il
suo gioco camomilla go go questa è la
flashlight cola del telefono
questa la torcia del telefono ma prima
che torcia c'avevo a torch ad alcun del
mio vabbè non scendiamo nel non family
friendly con questa parte cui abbiamo
appurato che non si aprono cipro 20 a
volta vorrei mai tornare qua
non siamo va bene io vorrei capire
veramente se avrete la porta d'uscita mi
ci gioco l'anello che si chiude come
arrivo lì si chiude dall'apparenza di
poter uscire ma non esco
[Musica]
è giocato mia demonio che brutta roba ho
visto che brutta roba off in questa è la
vera mente per una brutta forte e la
madonna tesoro non 16 calmiamo la donna
che brutta roba che ho visto mi salta in
bocca su tizio al momento all'altro
l'infarto è lì che bello
beh diario con azione ai paesi cisis
questi stanno ha parlato a manichini mi
fai una foto già che ci sei il cambio
foto profilo di facebook c'è anche la
zia la zia la smetti di suicidarsi nel
bagno per favore grazie terzi guardi c'è
qualcosa tra i denti non solo e io
facciamo che me ne vado
hai visto da un lato la zia io non la
vedo più vabbè io vado avrai loro è
giusta china foto machu febbraio sarò ok
e chi sono le due ragazze i preferiti io
con loro due è comparsa la zia comunque
un momento l'euro che mi fermi gli sto
parlando le idee non poi sono sentiti
non credo non ci hanno le orecchie però
sono bravi a scomparire quello glielo
riconosco tra l'altro la porta si è
sbarrata adesso non posso più uscire
sono veramente troppo contento e casse
sono dimesse cosa non prima va bene
posso prendere la macchina fotografica
si crea per svilupparla nella camera di
sopra quella nella dark room a malapena
quando scatta foto con lo smartphone
sondare sulla galleria per ritrovarla
figurati senso sviluppare le foto ma
sviluppi sviluppi veloce siamo mica qui
a pettinar le bambole
siamo a pettino ai manichini bella staff
è carinissima che c'e devo fare questa
foto qua che non ho capito la forte in
giro ho trovato una foto
se vi può interessare lo so c'è io ve
l'ho sviluppata io ve la riporto giu se
lo fa con una foto così forse devo
ritrovare questo luogo in casa possibile
allora eccolo e questo c'era una tendina
qua che non c'è più
rialzo ok
a posca tenda ad aster salve sull meno
male che ci siete voi perché guarda da
solo non riesco a fare una sequenza
please do not funzioni it on the chair
eroina corni sì non capisco cosa dici
sono italia parla italiano stanno
parlando di poter fare del tempo io ne
prendo una tazza o se volete frutti di
bosco grazie non potevo aprire i
cassetti non c'è più cassetto ok
torniamo giu la foto è rimasta tra
l'altro sospesa nel nulla vi piacerà al
tavolino
vabbè dai prendo una vera possiamo cosa
me ne faccio lista foto ho avuto un
mezzo soffietto al cuore sincero no con
me come dai era bellissimo mi piace un
sacco
porca vacca perché giochi bene finiscono
porca eva quadro completo lo gioco giuro
era bellissimo era finissima fatto
troppo bene non c'erano già upscale però
l'attenzione si palpava con la manina
prega solidi spero che vi sia piaciuto a
me un sacco cioè il video dal gioco il
video che vi è piaciuto mettete mi piace
ha stupito ma l'inizio però abbiamo
ceduto ragazzi come se non dover cercare
di iniziare
sono stato per i siti schiette e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vinto bene
[Musica]